Now to discuss conservative attorney
George Conway.
George Trump could be the first former
president in American history
to be arrested.
Do you think this
case, what we know of it
involving Stormy Daniels
and the falsification
of business records,
do you think it really rises
to the magnitude of such
an unprecedented step?
Well, I
you know, this
wouldn't be the first case
I would bring against them
if I were
if I were the director of a movie
trying to figure out
how to hold a properly organized this.
But the fact of the matter
is, it's a real case.
And the thing to remember about it,
and particularly
when you hear
the gaslighting commentary
of Speaker McCarthy, of former speaker
former Speaker McCarthy in
this case was originally a federal case
brought against
Michael Cohen for campaign finance
violations, failure
to report basically a straw donors,
B reimbursement.
This was a case
brought by the Trump Justice Department.
The Southern District of New York
brought this case
and told the sentencing judge again.
The Trump administration told
the sentencing judge for Michael Cohen
that what
Cohen's crimes
were committed at the behest of
and this is actually
for the benefit for Donald Trump.
And so these are serious.
This is this is serious.
These are serious offenses.
The thing about Trump is he's
committed so many others
that it kind of looks less
serious than, say, trying to
overturn the election
and trying to overturn the Constitution
and so on and so forth.
So that
that's the only reason why
this case of any was
it was
that it should have been
brought as a federal case
at noon on January 20th, 2021.
So that's interesting.
So you think anyone protesting
this case, theoretically in order to be
intellectually consistent,
if they weren't protesting
the prosecution of Michael Cohen
by I believe it was then U.S.
attorney Michael Berman,
is that right,
who Donald Trump had appointed
if they didn't?
Jeffrey Berman.
Jeffrey Berman. I'm sorry.
If they didn't protest that,
then they shouldn't be protesting this.
It's entirely inconsistent
intellectually.
Well, it's
consistent to say that this was a
this was a political prosecution.
I mean, this these are real potential
campaign finance violations
when you're doing something.
And look,
let's let's not
they say,
oh, it was because he was afraid
of Melania.
This happened days
before a presidential election
and that was, frankly, stormy leverage.
That was smarmy
and her lawyer and leverage on Trump
because of the possibility
of a last minute disclosure.
And the reason why the money was paid
was to keep her quiet
before the election.
It was a contribution.
It was
it was something
that Michael Cohen
put to put up his own money,
borrowed from his home equity loan,
and then he was reimbursed.
And both
the making of that illegal contribution
and the wee wee bookkeeping
and the reimbursement were legal.
And the only question,
I think in New York,
London, New York, possibly
whether it's a misdemeanor
or a felony,
you tweeted that Donald Trump's best
defense would be to plead insanity.
Was what you just being cheeky or
do you mean that
I was being a little
bit cheeky, you know, and it's
only the defense is actually pretty hard.
Under under most jurisdictions law
you have to show that a person
is incapable
of determining right from wrong
in order and acting on that basis.
And Trump,
you know, always,
almost always does the wrong thing.
But he knows the difference between
right and wrong.
And the reason
why he knows the difference
between right
and wrong is always denying things.
When people say he did something wrong
and he's always accusing people
of doing something,
that the things that he did.
So he knows what the difference between
right and wrong is.
And so in an insanity defense
really wouldn't work.
That said, he is clearly decompensating
in some sense
that if you look at the
social media
tweets
that he has put out
over the last few days,
I mean, this is not this is not a man who
is not a man in
full command of his faculties.
I want to get your reaction
to one of the many claims
we're hearing
from Republican congressmen,
this one from Kelly
Armstrong of North Dakota earlier today.
Everybody's
going to have their own agenda,
their own opinion on these things.
But I can tell you from my experience,
if the defendant wasn't Donald Trump,
this wouldn't be brought by a D.A.
That that's just the truth.
Now, I keep hearing that and that yet
I remember
I don't know how similar a case it is,
but I remember the prosecution
of former Senator John Edwards,
and that was during
the Obama administration.
And that was for
not exactly the same thing,
but it was a bout of fund raisers
and donations
and a girlfriend
and extramarital girlfriend.
Were they similar?
They found that they found a rich woman,
a rich old lady to give money to Edward's
baby mama, in essence, to keep
they keep her out of sight
and keep her out of
help the campaign.
And I think the problem in that case
wasn't a legal problem.
It was just that
I think by the time of trial,
the woman who gave the money was
was really not in a position
to testify
because of her physical condition.
But that said, it's
a perfectly it's a valid legal theory.
It was a valid federal legal theory.
It should have been.
But the fact of the matter is,
this case isn't being brought
because he's Donald Trump.
This case wasn't brought by the U.S.
government
during Trump's administration
when Trump's administration
was investigating it
and told federal courts
that this was a crime.
He was not prosecuted
because he was president.
So it's actually the exact
opposite of what
this congressman is saying.
Interesting.
George Conway, thanks so much.
Enjoy the the slopes behind you.
I'm jealous.